[MUSIC PLAYING]
RICHARD: Let me begin by
introducing Joanne Lipman.
She has achieved great success
in the world of publishing,
beginning as a reporter at
"The Wall Street Journal,"
on to being an entrepreneur
at "The Wall Street
Journal" in Conde Nast,
in starting new editorial
properties within
those organizations.
She moved on to Gannett, where
she ultimately became editor
in chief of "USA Today"
and the chief content
officer of Gannett overall.
So also, interestingly, I
had the tremendous pleasure
of getting to know Joanne
over the last year and a half,
as we were both members of the
Knight Commission on Trust,
Media, and Democracy.
And we're, frankly,
at the latter stages
of completing that work, and
will publish a report sometime
in the next few months.
Which simply, to me, says
that Joanne is obviously not
shy about taking on very
challenging questions.
So what's the future of gender
equality in the workplace?
What's the future of democracy
in the world of the internet?
These are vexing problems.
And they don't, as we know, have
necessarily simple solutions.
They have constructive
approaches, but not
necessarily simple solutions.
So we're here to talk
about Joanne's book.
By the way, we do have several
dozen copies available.
It is available also on Kindle,
her book "That's What She Said,
What Men Need to Know and Women
Need to Tell Them About Working
Together."
So let me just open up
by saying that these are,
as we know, very challenging
times for our society,
in many, many ways.
These are also very
challenging times at Google,
as we well know.
And this last hour
is ample evidence
of that, of the
work we need to do,
of the justifiable
concerns that many of us
have about the urgency in
addressing these challenges.
And I hope today--
and I get verklempt.
I hope today an indication
of our cultural commitment
to addressing them.
And, again, it's
not over in a day.
But I do think there's symbolism
to what happened today,
and hopefully symbolism
that has long value.
I might come back to that later.
So let's get into this.
Joanne, I think your book--
and I'd strongly
urge you to read it.
It's filled with a
tremendous amount
of information,
examples, and data
about the environment we're in.
And Joanne does an excellent
job of illuminating
those issues of
unconscious bias,
of how women feel in the
workplace, of how they are
often perceived in
the workplace in ways
that we know they
should not be perceived.
And, as typical
with these sessions,
I will, after the first
two or three or so,
open it up to all questions.
But let me start off with a few.
And your book makes, I think,
a really important point
that, in addressing
these issues,
it's how do we take
constructive approaches?
How do we look more at
the dos than the don'ts?
And I think we'll come
back to that several times
in this conversation.
So let me just start off.
Based on your
work, based on even
what you might know at a
fairly high level about Google,
what are the several things
that you would advise Google,
advise Googlers, male
or female, in guiding
that evolution of a
gender equal culture?
JOANNE LIPMAN: Sure.
So first of all, thank
you guys for having me.
And thank you for having
me today of all days.
So I actually got here just
as the walkout was happening.
So I got to be a part of it.
And I was so energized by it.
And also, I had been following
@GoogleWalkout on Twitter,
watching this cascade around the
world, which is amazing to see.
But what I loved being
outside with all of you
guys was how many men
I saw, and how many
male allies, and knowing
Googlers like Richard.
And that is actually why I
wrote "That's What She Said."
And actually the reason
that I wrote the book
in the first place is
because I grew up--
my first two decades
of my career I
spent at "The Wall
Street Journal,"
where almost all of my
colleagues were men.
My sources were men.
My mentors were all men.
And I had a very good
experience in a very male
dominated organization in
a male dominated industry.
And yet, as I rose up
the leadership ranks,
I started getting invited to
more and more of these women's
leadership conferences.
And at a certain
point I just became
a little bit frustrated,
because these conversations were
phenomenal.
Women's conversations
with one another,
when we talk amongst
ourselves, we
talk all the time about
the issues we face at work.
And I don't mean just the
extremes of sexual abuse.
But the everyday things of being
marginalized and overlooked,
interrupted, not
taken seriously,
not taken as seriously
as the guy next to us.
And we talk about it all
the time with each other.
But men are not part
of that conversation.
And actually the book
grew out of a piece
I ended up writing for "The
Wall Street Journal" called
"Women At Work,
a Guide For Men,"
and in which I say-- and this
is the point of the book--
women talking to each other,
it's a great conversation.
It's half a conversation.
And that gets us
to half a solution.
So the only way we
solve this is for us
to all understand we
need to work together,
and bring men into
the conversation.
So at a high level, that's
the most important thing.
That was amazing
to see that today.
I also love seeing men
here, which is great.
And I love being invited here.
I've been talking to a lot of
male dominated organizations.
There are so many things
that we can talk about.
And I actually
have a cheat sheet
in the back of the book on
10 things you can do right
now to close the gender gap.
But it really breaks down into
things that individuals can do
and things that
organizations can do.
And just to talk for a
moment organizationally,
because I do think a lot of the
things that were on those five
changes actually mirror things
that I recommend in the book.
Things like a gender
wage gap analysis
that is transparent I think
is very, very important.
There's a law now in the UK
that just went into effect
that companies must report
their gender wage gap analysis.
And would anyone
like to take a guess
of how many companies
in the UK pay
women more than they pay men?
AUDIENCE: Zero?
JOANNE LIPMAN: Zero.
Exactly.
Zero.
Well, it's really important
to know that information
so that you can act
on that information.
There are companies as
well that actually build it
into compensation
to incentivize,
not just hiring, but training,
recruitment, promotion,
and retaining diverse talent.
Not just women, but
all diverse talent.
I think that that's
very helpful.
And then there are things
that we as individuals can do.
But the bottom line
for organizations
is it really must
come from leadership.
This is something I've learned.
I've been traveling
around the country.
And I think the frustration
that led to the walkout today
was a frustration in
that it's not that--
there's thousands of
women who have walked out.
It's not like thousands of
women have been sexually abused
at work.
But I think it's the
signal that that sends.
When you have some bad
behavior at the top,
the signal that it sends to
the rest of the organization
and through the
culture is that if you
have that kind of
behavior at the top, then
what does that say
about how we value
women in the rest
of the organization?
And that translates into things
like respect, which there's
a huge respect gap
between men and women
that has been documented
in the research.
And it's those kinds of things
that I think that individually
we all can address.
RICHARD: Well, and as
you point out often,
role modeling is key.
JOANNE LIPMAN: Absolutely.
And awareness is key.
I mean, I talk a lot
about unconscious bias.
When you read the
book, there's actually
a chapter focused on
Google and its efforts
to combat unconscious bias.
And I spent time with a
fabulous unconscious bias expert
in your New York
office, Brian Welle.
He was absolutely spectacular.
Great researcher.
But I think that the question
really in unconscious bias
is, it's so important.
You have to be aware
of it all the time.
And I know you guys have
unconscious bias trainings.
But a couple of
hours of training
does not transform a culture.
And so there's so
many things that we
need to be aware of
just in everyday life.
Unconscious bias-- I'm sure
you all know what it is,
cause you've all been trained.
Right.
It's these biases we have
that are buried so deep
inside of us, we don't
even realize they exist.
And we all have them.
Men.
Women.
Black.
White.
No matter what,
we all have them.
RICHARD: Effectively
about our tribes,
in a sense, our
sense of tribalism.
JOANNE LIPMAN: It is.
It is.
And so we're not always
aware of how that impacts us.
But just as a couple
of for instances,
it turns out women are
interrupted three times more
frequently than men.
Northwestern
actually did a study
of the Supreme Court
of the United States
and found that the
female Supreme Court
justices are interrupted
three times more
frequently than male
Supreme Court justices.
Another thing that
probably every woman here
has experienced
is that thing that
happens when you're in a room.
Generally, if women are
in a minority in a group,
in a meeting,
which has certainly
happened to me many times,
and most of you probably,
it is true.
Your voices aren't heard.
This research shows that if you
make up 30% or less of a room,
literally the ear is tuned to
the male voices in the room.
So how many women here
have had that experience,
where you say
something in a meeting?
And it's like nobody heard it.
Crickets.
Right?
And then two minutes later a guy
repeats exactly what you just
said, and everybody
just turns to him.
They're like, Dave,
great idea you had, Dave.
Well, that's happened
to me a million times.
And I used to think
it was just me.
But it turns out it
is in the research.
That is actually
something that is very
common to almost all women.
RICHARD: You mentioned
unconscious bias training.
One of the things I
was surprised to learn
from the book was
the research that
tells us that diversity
training doesn't work
and that it's, in fact,
counterproductive.
It felt counterintuitive to me.
But also, as you
went into it, wise.
And so I think it'd be
great for you to explain
like why is that the case?
And more importantly,
what do you
think that tells us about how we
guide our workforce in building
a gender equal culture?
JOANNE LIPMAN: Yeah.
So there is actually research.
A Harvard professor by
the name of Frank Dobbin
did this research
where he looked at--
and this was at traditional
diversity training.
So he looked at 30 years
of diversity training
at more than 800 companies.
And he found that
for two groups,
for women, as well as
for black men and women
that not only did it not work.
It actually made things
worse for those two groups.
In other words, those
two groups would
have fared better in those
companies had there been
no training at all.
And he delved into
the reasons for this.
And there were a
variety of reasons.
But one of them was
that it was resentment
on the part of the
primarily white men who
were subject to the training.
So I went back and found some
of these traditional trainers.
And one of them actually
said to me, look,
when we started diversity
training about 30 years ago,
it was in response to lawsuits.
And he said our
process basically
was beating white guys over
the head with a two by four
and trying to make
them feel guilty.
And he said, and if
they cried, even better.
So it had exactly the reverse
of the intended effect.
That actually has
engendered and led
to the rise of
unconscious bias training.
Because the idea with
unconscious bias training is we
all have it.
We're not trying to make
you feel guilty about it.
We're just trying to
help you interrupt it.
But I think the issue with
unconscious bias training,
you still do have people,
including you had a situation
here at Google as well.
You do have people
who still feel
like they're getting beaten up.
But I think the
larger issue really
is simply unconscious
bias training is not,
in and of itself, a fix.
It is a piece of a culture.
And that's what we really
need is a cultural overhaul.
And that's not
specific to Google.
Our corporate life
in this country
really needs to have
an overhaul in how
we interact with one another.
RICHARD: I can't help
but think there's
something very deep in that.
I mean, you mentioned,
for instance,
just the dynamics of how
we guide, irrespective
of this issue, how we give
criticism to people, say,
in performance reviews.
In one of the things
you mentioned.
And also in terms of being
too shy about giving harsh
guidance.
But, to me, I think the
larger lesson, which
I think we learn in all kinds
of ways in terms of parenting,
is like it's always
so much better
to give an individual guidance
to how they can succeed,
and assume they will succeed,
rather than telling them
about all the things
they've done wrong,
and assuming they will
continue to do it wrong.
JOANNE LIPMAN: Right.
I would totally agree with that.
I would add in, there
is some research
that shows us some of the biases
that creep into performance
reviews.
So one actually is--
this stunned me actually.
So in writing the
book, I traveled
around the country
and the world,
seeking out primarily men
in positions of authority
who are trying to
close the gender gap.
And the first question--
Cause I wanted to learn from
them, what are the strategies?
Like what are success
stories and strategies
that we can all learn from?
But the first question
I would always ask
them is, tell me what
perplexes or frustrates you
about the women
who you work with?
And I was stunned by how
many of these men said,
I'm afraid she'll cry.
Now, it is actually
true that younger women
do cry, biologically
speaking, more than older men.
But the interesting
thing is these men
were afraid that they would
unintentionally say something
to a subordinate female
and unintentionally hurt
her feelings.
But here's the thing.
The research tells us, and
actually any women in this room
will also tell us that when
a woman does cry at work
it is not because her
feelings are hurt.
It is because she's pissed off.
She's furious.
A woman crying at
work is actually
pretty much the same thing
as a man yelling at work.
But these executive men.
It has a serious consequence.
Actually Catalyst did this
survey of executive men
and said, what might stand
in the way of you supporting
gender equality at work?
And it was more
than 70% of them--
I think it was 74%
of them cited fear.
And part of the fear was
fear of loss of status,
particularly among other men.
But part of the fear was fear
of saying the wrong thing.
And what that led to-- and
other research has shown
this-- is that these men who
were in positions of authority
are afraid to give candid
feedback to women in the way
that they give it to men.
And what that
results in is women
getting many more of
these evaluations that
talk about their
personality, and often
have a personality critique.
She's abrasive, or brash,
or aggressive, in a bad way.
Versus men, who tend to
get very constructive,
performance oriented critiques.
And, again, that's
another thing.
It's very subtle.
But what that ends up
doing is giving men
more of the information
they need to succeed,
and the women aren't getting it.
RICHARD: And again,
so many insights
about unconscious bias,
into our cultural biases,
into stereotypical
models of male behavior,
stereotypical models of societal
behavior, for that matter.
And like you mentioned in the
book, that you wear high heels
to, in a sense, put
yourself closer,
on a more equal footing,
which interestingly
resonated with me in that I'm
not a particularly tall guy.
I've raised a lot of money
from venture capital firms.
And the end of that
process is always
you presenting to the full
partnership at their Monday
meeting.
And talk about macho,
ego driven rooms.
It's like way up there.
And the ethos in VC firms
is, the idea is one thing,
but it's all about the CEO
in a pretty extreme way.
And when I would go into
those presentations,
I would literally sort
of puff myself up.
I would stand several
inches taller.
I would get closer to people.
I'd use my arms.
I would speak more loudly
to kind of present myself
in the way they were
expecting to see me.
And I think there are obvious
techniques that work for all.
But I couldn't help
in thinking about that
and saying-- in fact, my
wife, by the way, she jokes.
She's like, you're the only
5'9" guy who thinks he's 6'2".
[LAUGHING]
JOANNE LIPMAN: I
thought you were 6'2".
RICHARD: See.
But are we playing into
patriarchal models with that?
I mean, to what extent is
it about patriarchal models?
Or is it about societal models?
And how does that matter to
what we're talking about?
JOANNE LIPMAN: Yeah.
Look, I mean, it
would be great for us
to be able to wipe out all
of these kinds of concerns
like that.
Right.
It would be terrific.
But until then,
there are strategies.
And what you experienced is
what women experience every day.
And often many times a day.
So I do wear high
heels every day.
And I always thought it was
because I worked around men,
and I wanted to have a
physically larger presence.
But it turns out that
taller women earn
8% more than shorter women.
Women who wear makeup earn
more than those who do not.
Women who are thin out
earn those who are heavy.
And people, generally, men and
women, who are better looking
earn more.
RICHARD: And taller.
JOANNE LIPMAN: And taller.
Earn more.
RICHARD: CEOs and height
is a fascinating--
JOANNE LIPMAN: Yep.
It is an actual--
it's a thing.
It's a real thing.
But for women, grooming
actually counts much more.
And there was this
great calculation.
Debora Spar, who was the
president of Barnard,
calculated that over
the course of her career
a professional woman will spend
a total of five full years
longer than her male
spouse or colleague
getting ready for work.
The hair, the makeup,
just maintenance.
Which I found fascinating.
But, again, the world
that we live in,
and including Google, I mean,
the work world that we live in
was created by men for men.
And so women are, in a
sense, trying every day.
There's 1,000 things
we do, some conscious,
some unconscious to try and fit
into the world created by men.
And a huge reason why I
wrote "That's What She Said,"
was to make men aware--
I actually geared
the book toward men,
even though it's for
women as well, obviously.
But I really want
to bring men in
to understand what some
of these issues are,
just so that they have
an awareness of it.
Because women are leaning in
so far we're falling over.
But the men who I
spoke to were awesome.
And these are guys
who realize that they
have to reach out as well.
It's not just a one sided thing.
And I do think that there's
been a little bit of too
much of an onus put
on women, particularly
in these past few years,
that it's all on us.
And we have to demand to
be paid what we're worth.
We have to go out there
and fix the patriarchy.
But, in fact, actually this
is a two sided equation.
And we need the men to recognize
that as well, and join us.
RICHARD: I'm going to
move to the audience.
There's a question
on the Dory that I
think relates to what
we're talking about here.
This person says, you have
talked about differences
in the ways that women
and men typically
present their thoughts.
Suggestions versus declarations.
Not all men and women
present in the typical way.
How much of the lack of
respect for those approaches
do you attribute to the
approach itself, the technique,
versus speakers' gender?
JOANNE LIPMAN: Yeah.
That's a great question.
And the first thing
I would say is
that it is documented that
women do use more hedging
language than men do.
And that would be things like,
I hate to bother you, but.
You know, this might be
a stupid question, but.
We use more up speak, like
when we ask a question, when
we mean a statement.
And we apologize all the time.
And we are not sorry.
But we use that verbal tic.
And we're highly aware
of these verbal tics.
And we try like crazy
to counteract them.
But the other
thing I will say is
I've heard from so many readers
of "That's What She Said,"
because all of this applies not
just to women, but to pretty
much anyone who's in an
under represented group.
And so much of the
research I cite also deals,
not just with women, but
with underrepresented groups.
And one of the groups of readers
that I have heard a lot from
is introverted men, who
say all of these behaviors
are my behaviors as
well, and I suffer
from the same consequences.
So I think it's highly relevant.
And that's why it's so
important to be aware of it,
because right now it is
the norm of behavior.
And women have spent many
years trying to fit that norm.
And what we need to do
is have men be aware,
and women, all of
us, kind of be aware
of these different
communication styles,
and just be more
sensitive to those.
RICHARD: Yeah.
I want to be specific to that.
And I'm going to take the
next question from the room.
So get your thoughts together.
A couple of things there.
You mention in the book about
how important mentoring is.
You mention how often senior
men are uncomfortable,
concerned about perceptions
in mentoring younger women,
which, frankly, I kind
of think is a cop out.
I think if we can't, as
professionals, figure out
how to manage that
dynamic, then probably you
shouldn't be doing
what you're doing.
But let's put that aside.
In my own experience,
particularly
in my more advanced
stage, as it were--
meaning I'm old, I
do enjoy, and one
of my great pleasures at Google
is trying to coach people.
I say try.
I don't know how
good at it I am.
But I've also sensed
that in this engineering
centric culture, it's not
just about men and women.
I mean, it's not just
about women in this regard.
That there are many folks
here who are introverted,
not self assertive.
But the question
I have for you is,
today I try to coach women in
pretty much the same way as I
coach men.
But are there
different approaches
that one should take place?
Or is it just about
different sensitivities?
JOANNE LIPMAN: So,
first of all, I 100%
agree with you about
being a cop out.
There are men out there
who say, oh, like #MeToo.
I'm never going to
talk to a woman.
I can't mentor a woman.
And that's just bullshit.
Sorry.
I have no patience for that.
That's generally men who
aren't mentoring women anyway.
But there are many, many
different ways to mentor.
And I think that the
big difference is,
and that we know
from the research
that women tend to have
mentors who give them advice.
Men tend to have what
are known as sponsors
who can get them promotions.
And so actually that Harvard
research I mentioned earlier,
Frank Dobbin, when he was
looking at what are solutions
that work, versus the old
fashioned diversity training,
one of them was formal
mentorship programs.
And the idea with a
formal mentorship program
is it's not that I am mentoring
Susan because she's a woman.
It is because I am
mentoring whoever it is
because they are in my field.
And very often what
ends up happening is
senior women end up
being paired with
or sought out by other
women, but they're not
in the same field.
They can't help.
Right.
And it's not gender
mentoring gender.
You want to be mentored by
somebody who can actually
help you advance.
And I think that's the
big, big difference.
RICHARD: Is there a
question in the room.
AUDIENCE: I think what you're
saying is so interesting,
because when I look back
over the course of my career,
no one has done more for me
in my career than white men.
Right.
And I work with so many women.
And I offer my
mentorship to them,
and sponsorship in
certain cases as well.
And what I often hear
is there's just not
enough females in
leadership positions.
So I just don't
have any mentors.
I don't have any sponsors.
And my thought there is like,
it doesn't have to be a woman.
JOANNE LIPMAN: Right.
AUDIENCE: Look to these men.
Because they are in
the positions of power.
And they will do a lot for you.
And I wonder if there's an
oversaturation of just--
like these men don't
have enough time to--
there's few of
them, I would say,
who are as connected
to women in the way
that the women want them to be.
And I'm wondering, what can
we do to enable more men
to understand how women
need to be mentored,
and what they expect
from sponsorships?
Because so much of it
comes back to your point
around women in a lot of
underrepresented groups
actually don't get the
critical skill based feedback
that they need.
They're not getting
skill based mentorship.
And that continues the
vicious cycle of people
not sort of understanding
what really needs to happen,
because there's a fear
of hurting feelings,
or that sensitivity.
So does that--
JOANNE LIPMAN: Yes.
You made a great point.
And actually what
you're talking about
is why this Harvard professor
said these formal programs are
actually more effective.
And, in fact, there are
a couple of organizations
that I cite in the book
that put into effect
these formal programs.
And they found that it helped
with retention and promotion
not just of the people
who are being mentored.
But it helped with
retention of the people who
were doing the mentoring, which
was also really interesting.
But yes.
I think we have to think about
that skills based mentoring.
We have a tendency,
all of us as humans,
to gravitate toward people
who remind us of ourselves.
And that has been a huge issue.
One of the solutions, one of
my recommendations in "That's
What She Said" is to
have a Rooney rule.
So you guys know what
the Rooney rule is?
It's in football.
If you have an opening, you
need to have a diverse slate
of candidates to choose from.
But what I'm recommending, and
what I learned from the men
who I interviewed was
that's not enough.
You actually need to have
a diversity of people
who are doing the interviewing.
And that goes to whether
they are thinking
about looking at
somebody to be promoted,
or filling an opening.
You need a diverse
slate of people.
Because if you've got
a bunch of white guys
who are evaluating a
diverse group of people,
you still do not get
an optimal result.
And the other thing I will
say as, so many companies
that I visit with say,
oh, we really want
women in our senior ranks.
But we can't find any.
And to them I say,
and to Google I say,
look in your junior ranks.
Look.
What's happening there?
Look at who are the
people who are coming in.
Look at every single
level, especially
in those low lower levels
leading to middle management.
Look at every level and
see who are you promoting
and who are you not?
Who are you losing
Because there is
leakage in there.
And there's people who are being
passed over who should not be.
And if you do that,
it's not going
to take you that long until
you've grown your own leaders.
Actually so I spoke at one
of the big consulting firms.
And I had dinner afterward
with a table of 10 senior women
at this consulting firm.
And they went around the
table, and all of them
had been recruited by other
major consulting firms,
because they were already
at a senior level.
And that's the problem.
If we're just shuffling
around the same too few women
at the top, we are not
going to get anywhere.
Right.
I spoke to a bank
that, before I went,
I did a little bit of research.
And I found that they
had made a commitment
to gender equality in 1982.
I'm speaking to a room.
I said, most of you guys
were not born in 1982.
You had plenty of time to get
yourself to gender equality.
But they're losing the
women on the way up,
and they're not growing
their own leaders.
And I think that
is so essential.
Not enough companies
are focused on that.
RICHARD: Yeah.
I think that's so true.
By the way, one other
thing, I think, again,
on trying to facilitate
mentoring and mentoring
programs, one thing I feel it's
also important to recognize
is to encourage people to
ask someone for mentoring.
Not be shy about that.
I mean, when you
think about it, it's
actually kind of a nice
ego inflating thing
if someone comes and
says, can you help me?
Like you know more than I do.
You've been around the
track a few more times.
That's a very simple path if you
can be comfortable doing that.
JOANNE LIPMAN: So that's the key
is if you can be comfortable.
I mean, yes, I agree.
That's a great idea.
But I think, again,
it puts the onus
on the person with less power.
And we put too much onus already
on the people with less power.
We need to put more on
the people with power.
And, in fact, while I
was writing the book--
and I was at
Gannet-- it actually
changed the way I managed.
And I started
realizing that when
we had openings, and especially
like with internal openings,
I'd have all these guys who
would put their hands up
for it.
But there would be women
or minority people of color
who were not putting
their hands up
who would have been very
qualified in the pool.
So I took it on myself to
say-- cause I was in the middle
of this research--
I was like, wait a second.
So I would actually go into the
newsroom and talk to people,
and bring them into my
office, and say, hey,
I see you didn't
put your hand up.
You should know that you are
qualified to be in this pool.
It doesn't mean that
you would get the job.
And I'm not telling you you
have to put your hat in.
But you should know that.
And if you're not
interested, let's
talk about what you might be
interested in down the line.
And I realized,
belatedly I think,
that it was really my
responsibility as a leader
to go out and make sure that
these people who have talent
are given these opportunities.
And it shouldn't always
be on their head.
RICHARD: Excellent point.
I'm going to move
to our virtual-- oh,
we have an un-virtual
audience right here.
[LAUGHS]
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
Sometimes at an
individual level,
we will see managers
behaving in ways
that are not as
egregious as firing,
but still are kind of leading
to outcomes that decrease
diversity.
And I have thought about
speaking up many a time,
and I've had male mentors for
me who cared about me personally
who advised me not to speak up,
that it would hurt my career.
And one of the few
times that I did
choose to do that,
suddenly I did feel
some pretty bad consequences.
So what is your advice to
people who are seeing things
that are in the gray area?
What kinds of actions
are actually productive,
cause I haven't figured it out?
JOANNE LIPMAN: Yeah.
This is where allyship
is so important.
I mean, what you're
talking about
is so common in
all organizations.
And I talk a lot about
different kinds of allies,
women with women, or with men.
But that's what's so important.
I mean, I think
one of the issues,
particularly that women
face, is particularly
if this behavior is
directed at them,
and maybe it doesn't rise
to the level of firing,
but it is demeaning,
perhaps, or dismissive,
and the women feel
like, ugh, I've
got to figure out how
to deal with this.
And that's where allies come in.
In the case that
you're talking about,
I would have hoped
that the mentors,
they would have stepped
up and intervened.
And that's the kind of behavior
that we want to encourage,
that kind of allyship.
And I tell people that your ally
can be somebody at your level.
It can be somebody in
a different department.
I have found in different
organizations sometimes
I have been
approached by somebody
who doesn't report to me
who's not in my department
to tell me about some
sort of behavioral issues
with a manager.
And it's really
important to do that.
And one of the
reasons it's important
is because I can say
almost every time, maybe
every time that has
ever happened to me,
where I've been approached
where somebody says,
I don't want to bring
it up to my boss, but--
almost always the person
they're talking about
has a history of bad behavior.
So you need to surface
that so that the person can
be either talked to,
disciplined, dismissed,
whatever the correct
course of action is.
Too often we stay quiet.
And that's why it's
important to have that ally.
And I'm sure, Richard,
you've probably
had this situation too.
You're one of the good guys.
Right?
So I can imagine somebody coming
to you and confiding in you.
But I would imagine you
wouldn't tell them to be quiet.
You would try and--
RICHARD: No.
I mean, and can't say
as I know always what
the perfect techniques are.
But yes.
In many of those
circumstances, I mean,
it's understandable that
the individual confronting
the manager is not likely
to achieve the best
result, in both ways,
for that matter,
and end up with a
consequence you don't like.
Which is why you'd like to think
that organizations would have
people and mechanisms to address
that, because in that context,
depending on the
circumstance, yeah,
there are ways to address that.
And there are ways
to address that
without the individual
being, in a sense, brought
into the equation.
JOANNE LIPMAN: Right.
RICHARD: It's bad behavior.
I don't have to
declare who complained.
There are lots of clever ways
to deal with that, I think,
if you try.
JOANNE LIPMAN: I
can mention actually
two quick ones, because these
both worked in real life.
So one was, I was talking
to a senior executive
while I was out on book tour.
And the senior executive of a
big consumer products company
came up to me to tell me.
He said he had a
team, senior team.
And he said, there was
a woman on his team.
And she was like a
real ball buster.
She was great.
Like he didn't worry about her.
But she came to him
privately and said,
hey, have you noticed that
when we are in our meetings
there is this particular guy
who every time I open my mouth,
he shuts me down,
or cuts me off,
or takes credit for my idea.
And this boss said,
actually I had not noticed.
But once I did, he said,
we made a secret pact.
And the secret pact
was, I was going
to be on the lookout
for that behavior.
And every time I
saw it, I was going
to intervene and back her up.
And he wouldn't have known
had she not mentioned that.
And one other example,
which happened with me,
was somebody not
in my department
came to me at an
organization and said,
I don't want to
complain to my own boss,
but there is a particular
guy who is dismissive.
And I know another woman
who quit because she didn't
like the way he treated her.
But it's not like he's hitting
on us, or anything like that.
It's just dismissive behavior.
So I actually went
to a friend in HR.
And the friend said,
I'm so glad you
came to me because that
particular guy has a record.
I didn't know that.
But that's why
it's so important.
Like they needed
this information.
They needed to know this
information so that they
could take the proper action.
RICHARD: In some
cases what I've done--
and, again, so much depends
on the circumstance,
is in providing that feedback
to the individual is you
sort of like multiply it.
Right.
And say like, I'm
getting feedback.
JOANNE LIPMAN: Yes.
RICHARD: And it's not
necessarily singular
if you're getting feedback.
JOANNE LIPMAN: Yep.
RICHARD: And it
obviously that doesn't
work in all circumstances.
And I get that.
I think one of the
last ones was like,
Richard, you use a
lot of foul language.
Some people are
uncomfortable with that.
And I see some people
I work with laughing.
I haven't yet mastered
the solution to that.
But I'm trying.
JOANNE LIPMAN:
Question over here.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
JOANNE LIPMAN: Hi.
AUDIENCE: So I have
a question about when
working towards
closing the gender gap,
how do we make sure that people
that don't identify as gender
binary fall through the cracks?
JOANNE LIPMAN: That's
a great question.
And I make a real effort
in "That's What She Said"
to look at research that is--
the book itself is gender,
but I make a real effort
to look at
underrepresented groups.
And I think what
you're talking about,
people that you're talking
about fall into the category
of underrepresented groups.
And if you're
talking about people
who are not gender binary, or
people who fall into other--
religious minority.
I mean, there are a lot of
people who, unfortunately,
experience these same issues.
And I think a lot of the
same strategies hold.
And I was very cognizant
of that as I put together
the cheat sheet at
the end of the book
for recommendations
of things we can do.
And I'm actually
working, as we speak,
on updating the
book for paperback
to look separately for
individuals, steps we can take,
and organizations, steps that
organizations should be taking.
RICHARD: Thank you.
I'm going to go to
our virtual audience.
How much of a company's
actions are attributed
to it being self-serving?
A quote I've heard is that human
resources will help someone
as long as it doesn't go against
the interests of the company.
JOANNE LIPMAN: Yeah.
So I think that your allies
when I'm talking about allyship
is not necessarily HR.
HR does have a role in
protecting the company.
What I strongly feel is the best
way to overhaul the culture,
it really does have to
start with the leadership.
The leadership has to
not just talk the talk,
but they have to walk the walk.
They have to model the behavior.
And I also think
that incentives need
to be modeled as
well, to incentivize
the right kinds of behaviors.
We all react according
to incentives.
And if our incentives
have nothing
to do with kind of the
inclusion and diversity,
then we're not going
to pay attention to it.
And I have met some amazing DNI
professionals in my travels.
But they alone cannot
change a culture.
Really only the
leadership can do that.
RICHARD: I'm going to probe
you to add a little bit more
to that, because it's absolutely
true that companies operate out
of self-interest.
I mean, they should.
It's the nature
of its existence,
rewarding its shareholders,
so on and so forth.
To me the objective,
indeed the opportunity,
is how do you guide that to
be more self enlightened.
Or enlightened self-interest
is what I'm trying to say.
And you talk a lot in
the book about examples
of how companies are stronger
when they have gender
diversity, how they design
better products when
they have gender diversity.
So to me, that's the
enlightened self-interest.
How do you build a
talented workforce?
JOANNE LIPMAN: Absolutely.
Absolutely.
So every piece of
research shows you,
and you've probably
heard some of this,
that a gender balanced
leadership and a gender
balanced organization is
actually more successful.
By every financial measure.
And that goes for your
board of directors.
Companies that have the
most women on boards
are more financially successful
than those with the least.
Companies with gender
balanced leadership
outperform those
without by a factor
of like a double digit
percentage in terms
of return on equity.
But also, work groups.
Gender balanced work groups
are better at problem solving.
They're more creative when
it comes to solutions.
There was even
this research that
showed that they are more
accurate in solving a murder.
There was this
research where they
had this all-male, all-female,
and mixed gender group,
and they gave them a real
life murder case to solve.
And both single sex groups had
so much fun with this exercise.
And they agreed very quickly
on who the culprit was.
And they were very
confident of the result.
The mixed gender
group took longer.
It was less fun.
There was more back and forth.
They were less
confident of the result.
But guess who was right.
They were right.
Because you need that input
from a variety of perspectives
to really come to your
ultimate best solution.
RICHARD: So another
question from the audience.
While Google strives
for diversity,
it can be a challenge when
rank and file managers do not
value diversity of
opinions, or recognize
employees who approach problems
from a different perspective.
How can that be managed?
Now, actually this kind
of hits home with me,
because this is
something where I feel I
often have to kind
of remind myself
to engender multiple
opinions, and, frankly,
break through my own thinking.
I mean, I think there's this
interesting psychological
element that as any of us become
more confident in what we do,
more confident in
whether it's leadership
skills or our knowledge, you
also inherently kind of start
to close your mind a little bit.
And it takes effort
to break through.
And I don't feel like
I've mastered that at all.
JOANNE LIPMAN: Yeah.
I think that is a great point.
And that's part of
the awareness factor.
Being aware that
you tend to like--
I've been in organizations where
they say, oh, the boss really
likes brassy women.
Well, what if you're
a quiet woman?
Right.
You really have
to check yourself.
And, again, I do think that
this is an issue that we
see a lot of in companies where
you have sort of enlightened
leadership-- particularly
in big companies--
enlightened leadership.
But then you hear,
you know what?
It's not trickling down.
I have a manager who doesn't
value what the company is
valuing, in terms of
diversity of opinion,
diversity of approach.
And I do think,
again, that is why
I think we have these
intractable cultural issues,
which is what leads
to things like today,
where we had thousands
of people in the walkout.
But ultimately,
sometimes that's what
you need to move the needle,
to actually affect change.
AUDIENCE: At the
beginning of the talk
you mentioned that women
only leadership trainings
and conversations can be so
valuable for that audience.
You also mentioned the
statistic about women getting
interrupted in mixed company,
and also diversity training
backfiring.
So I wonder, how
do you recommend
that we bridge those divides,
besides just sort of waiting
for male allies to self identify
and proactively approach
the group in order to learn more
about the women's perspective?
JOANNE LIPMAN: Right.
So I actually advise women's
ERGs, Employee Resource Groups,
to invite men.
You don't have to invite
them all the time.
But there is a great example
of a firm where it was
a very male dominated company.
And they had a women's meeting.
It's not a company
as big as Google.
So they had an all
women's meeting
for all of their North
America operations.
And they decided we're going
to have just a women's meeting.
And then the few senior
women said, you know what?
For a portion of this
meeting we're each
going to invite a senior man.
And it turned out that those
invitations were so coveted
that all the senior men were
like lobbying to get invited.
And like, did you get invited?
Right.
It was like a big deal.
And the beauty of that was
that these senior men came.
They wouldn't have thought
of volunteering themselves.
But when they were invited
into this conversation, first
of all, they were able to hear
what's going on with the women.
But secondly, and I think
this is just as important,
they were able to create
these bonds and relationships
with the women in the firm.
And they were exposed to
the junior women in the firm
as well, who they
normally would not
have really interacted with.
So that means, and
this is what they
found, that when it comes
time for big assignments,
for the star assignments, when
it comes time for promotions,
these younger women
are now known.
They're top of mind.
And it actually helps with
bringing them all together.
So I do think that we have
to bring in both sides here.
And when I go and talk
to women's groups,
I always ask them
to invite some men.
I'm speaking tomorrow.
There's a women's power
summit in Hollywood.
So I'm going to LA to
talk at this meeting.
But I am in the one session
where it's about men.
And we'll be talking with men.
And men are invited
into the group.
Because I feel really strongly
that's where we need to go.
And the men are
excited to be there.
RICHARD: By the way, you spent
so much time on this book.
You did a ton of research.
What surprised you?
What challenged your own
assumptions and conclusions?
JOANNE LIPMAN: So a lot.
But I would say probably
one of the top issues
that I found as I was
doing the research--
and there's about 50 pages of
research notes in the back.
As I was diving
into the research
I came across so many of these
issues that I, my entire life,
have thought they were just me.
I thought it was my
problem and just me.
And I was stunned to find
that it is not just me,
that it is common to women.
It is common to people in
underrepresented groups.
And so I think that was
probably the biggest surprise.
And then the other part
of it on the plus side
was it really did change the
way I behave as a manager,
both in terms of things
like being really focused
on the people who are not
raising their hands for a job.
And also being
really focused on who
is in the conversation
when you're
talking about who
should get a promotion
or who should get a bonus.
Right.
Understanding that we need
that diversity of opinion.
RICHARD: Being no other
questions on the Dory
here, how has the experience
of the book impacted you
in the sense of the next
chapter of your own career?
I mean, you achieved
great professional success
in media organizations,
leadership positions.
But this is a very different
role that you're in.
So where do you see
this taking you,
professionally, personally?
JOANNE LIPMAN: Yeah.
It's been fascinating.
So since the book came out,
I've actually been speaking.
I've been kind of
nonstop talking,
speaking with, meeting
with organizations.
And what happened was I started
the book three years ago.
So this was long before #MeToo.
And then #MeToo happened.
And on the plus side, there
is a growing realization
among organizations,
including very male dominated
organizations like this one
that we haven't done enough.
And that there are things
that we have tolerated that we
shouldn't be tolerating.
And there is a lot
of soul searching
about what do we do about it?
So I've been unexpectedly--
I expected I would write the
book, and go on book tour
for two weeks, as
one does with a book.
And instead it's just been
sort of endlessly rolling,
because there is
a lot of interest
among these organizations
in trying to crack
the nut of where do we go next?
And how do we solve this issue?
I will also tell you, I
have some frustrations
in that it's been a year since
#MeToo, since Harvey Weinstein.
And there's been a lot
of talk, which is great.
There has not been
enough action.
And, again, I come back
to the walkout today,
which I found so inspiring.
But what the walkout
is doing is it
is a microcosm, or
maybe a macrocosm,
of what I am seeing
around the country
as I talk to companies
in other industries
who are saying exactly
what you guys are saying,
which is, OK, we hear you, that
you're saying the right things.
But we need to see action.
We need to see movement.
And that is not
unique to Google.
I am seeing that all
over the country.
And, in fact, globally as well.
I've been traveling
internationally as well,
talking about the same
issues, and seeing
the same conversation.
RICHARD: Well, I do hope
that you're thinking
and expressions on this, it can
help move that forward further.
Obviously, this is not
likely to be a short battle.
So I so appreciate what you've
done, what you've shared.
I mean, as I said
at the beginning,
I think these are just
extraordinary challenging
times, divisive times in so
many dimensions in our society.
And for gender equality,
the situation in politics,
I so believe that the only
way we can address divisions
is to find a way
to build bridges,
is to find a way to talk
across the divide, to find
the right language,
the right solutions,
the right constructive
approaches.
This has been an interesting
and challenging time at Google.
I've worked here
for nearly 10 years.
And I have always
believed, and I
do believe that it's a very
different company than most.
It's a company that
cares about principles,
that cares about
its culture, which
doesn't mean it's perfect.
It's not.
In fact, it won't ever be.
And I think that we
have to always assume
that our culture is not perfect.
But I do think our
only way forward
is to engage, to challenge
each other's perspectives,
challenge each other
productively, constructively,
and give them paths to success,
rather than just assume
failure.
JOANNE LIPMAN: There
are also some things--
and I know we're
running out of time.
But there are also
some things that are
very specific to technology.
So I on just two quick ones.
One is just in
terms of algorithms,
and who's doing the coding,
who's code is accepted.
You probably know
this, but there's
been some blind taste tests.
So there was one
done with GitHub,
which has open source coding.
And when coding was
submitted anonymously,
women's code was accepted
more often than men's code.
So you could conclude that
women are better coders.
But when names were
attached to the code,
men's code was accepted at a
greater rate than women's code.
There was an
engineer at Facebook
who did a similar experiment.
And Facebook disputes this.
But this engineer
claimed that code
written by females
at Facebook was
35% less likely to be accepted
than code written by men.
And then the other piece
that that works into
is your algorithm.
So when I go out on the road I
have like a little PowerPoint
that when I talk about
unconscious bias,
I show just Google
image searches
for various things that show
partly our unconscious bias.
One example is
while I was writing
the book I just did a search
for CEO, an image search.
And it was all men,
except for one woman.
And the one woman
was CEO Barbie.
And that reflects our
own unconscious bias,
but it also is spit out
to us by an algorithm.
And the algorithms are
largely written by men.
So we have these very ingrained,
not intentional, but sort
of ingrained issues that I
think also are specific to tech.
And then one other
that I would mention
is just simply, in working on
the book, I spent time here.
And I spent time in the
Chelsea office in New York.
And I loved it.
And I had a great time.
But I come from a
male dominated world.
But I noticed that to go
to the cafe in New York,
you pass the LEGO room.
You pass the game room.
And at the end after
spending time and hearing
about all the great things
you were doing to try and get
to gender balance, I just
spoke to a group of women
in the New York office.
And just as we're walking
through that office I said,
I see the guys in the game room.
I said, do you guys ever
go to the game room?
And they're like,
are you kidding?
We want to be taken seriously.
We would never do that.
And it's just these
little things.
And it wasn't like they
were complaining about it.
But it's a very
gendered environment.
And it just made me wonder.
Because it really was decorated.
I had this sense of deja vu.
And I swear to god,
I finally realized
that the Google office was
decorated like the bedroom
of my 10-year-old son.
And it made me wonder like
what would happen if the Google
office were decorated like
a stereotypical 10-year-old
daughter, with purple, and
pink, and fluffy things,
and glitter guns.
Right.
Like how would the men feel
if that's the environment
they worked in every day.
So it's not intentional at all.
But it sort of has an
impact on the culture
at large, and how women feel,
and how comfortable they
feel in the culture.
RICHARD: Again, thank you
hugely for what you've
done, for all the
work you've done,
and for sharing
that with us today.
And I hope we might have
a conversation a year
from now, two years from
now, three years from now.
And we might see progress
having been made.
JOANNE LIPMAN: Fantastic.
Well, thank you for having me.
Thank you, guys.
[APPLAUSE]